[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview notre
invité est un ex commando marine louis
saillants l'auteur de chefs de guerre
aux éditions à maroeuil dans cet ouvrage
il nous emmène dans les coulisses de la
guerre contre le djihadisme au sahel
une plongée dans le réel captivant son
objectif faire comprendre les enjeux de
la guerre contre le terrorisme
mais raconter aussi le quotidien des
commandos-marine rompu aux opérations
spéciales et leur sens du sacrifice
bonjour luis ayant merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors vous avez vous avez quitté lé
commandos marine est ce qui vous a fallu
une autorisation pour raconter avec
autant de précision ce que vous avez
vécu c'est un récit original dont je
suis l'auteur à 100% mais en moins j'ai
pris des précautions
dans ce récit afin de ne pas mettre en
danger mes camarades un pas afin de ne
pas porter atteinte à l'image des armées
donc avec toutes ces mesures préalables
j'ai pu emprunter des chemins qui sont
inhabituelles disons pour un militaire
mais qui qui ont été possibles pour moi
la sortie de votre ouvrage coïncide avec
une actualité forte au sahel
est ce que c'est un pur hasard ou pas du
tout c'est un pur hasard
il n'y a aucune chronométrie il n'y a
aucune j'avais aucune prévision dans la
promotion de ce livre c'est arrivé au
moment du ch et 5 salles et c'est bien
tombé
les premiers journalistes nous ont
alertés sur ce fait là et les choses se
sont faites naturellement en parcourant
en tout cas votre ouvrage je repensais à
la décision d' emmanuel macron de
maintenir l'engagement des troupes
françaises au sahel
est ce qu'à votre avis et une décision
de bon sens alors je ne m'exprimerai pas
clairement là dessus puisque j'ai un
devoir de réserve et que
monsieur emmanuel macron et le chef des
armées donc je ne remettrai pas cette
décision en question ici en tout cas et
il sera peut être l'objet de réflexion
plus approfondie et plus tard je pose
cette question parce que il ya des
pertes et humaine et vous raconter dans
votre ouvrage au tout début la douleur
que vous ressentez après la perte de
deux collaborateurs regard le feu
s'éteint c'est une situation à laquelle
on se prépare mais à laquelle mais
jamais prêt
c'est un c'est un jeu dangereux que
celui de la guerre et perdre des
camarades est toujours un sacrifice très
douloureux mais vous comprenez bien le
sens vous des enjeux de cette guerre
contre le terrorisme au sahel
ce qui pousse en tout cas la france à a
continué sur place à maintenir ses
militaires dans la région
oui oui alors le long jeu il est très
simple il est peut-être un peu
difficilement compréhensible lorsque
nous sommes à distance lorsqu'on est
loin de ces théâtres ça peut paraître un
peu flou je pense qu'il ya aussi
beaucoup de détournements médiatique les
les gens qui donnent les informations
sur les théâtres parfois utilise les
médias pour envoyer de fausses nouvelles
afin d'alimenter un parti ou l'autre ce
qui est important de se rappeler c'est
que l'ennemi là-bas parfaitement
légitime on parle de djihadistes
on parle de gens qui recrutent des
enfants qui égorge des gens par dizaines
hommes femmes enfants vieillards
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême
donc ne vous imaginez pas un seul
instant que je questionnerait le
la légitimité des combattants français
et c'est une guerre qui se poursuit en
ce moment même absolument nous parlons
les français ont déployé des moyens sur
toute la zone du sahel
on a des moyens de surveillance sur
toute la zone avec nos alliés et ont
fait un travail est en tout cas les
armées françaises font un travail
admirable là bas vous vous décrivez avec
beaucoup de précision les faits qu'on
finit finalement pas rentrer un peu dans
votre tête
votre mémoire elle est infaillible
assauts points c'est très étonnant non
pas du tout pas du tout j'ai eu recours
à des notes que j'avais pris sur le
terrain à des archives que j'avais
conservé à droite à gauche et donc j'ai
eu un cadre collection qui m'a permis en
fait de rassembler ces informations là
des petits détails que mon glisser les
camarades sur certaines situations afin
de m'aider avoir une meilleure vision
possible mais c'est ce que je dit en
préambule de bouquins je me suis
astreint à raconter les choses le plus
au plus proche de ce que mon souvenir me
le permettait et tout ce qui dans le
bouquin est vrai je n'ai j'ai simplement
retirées ou survoler certains détails
qui sont délicats et décale je ne peux
pas parler pardon vous dites que pour
chaque mission réussie vous n'en tirez
aucune gloire ni odeur ni récompense
simplement le sens du devoir accompli
est ce que c'est vraiment l'esprit qui
règne au sein des armées françaises oui
absolument mais on est formé pour faire
ses missions là et lorsque nous le
faisons la première récompense c'est
d'avoir accompli la mission
le chef nous nous récompenserons
derrière mais tout ça ça restera entre
nous en quelque sorte ce qui est à vegas
reste à vegas
donc c'est pas du tout des gloires
public qu'on va qu'on va rechercher dans
ses missions la alors vous avez vous
renoncé à une carrière dans
l'aéronautique pour les commandos marine
vous dites une voie choisie
des raisons propres à chacun vos raisons
à vous je pense que j'avais envie de
vivre une aventure sur le terrain avec
avec un sens de la fraternité
et puis d'aller au combat physiquement
d'être physiquement impliqué dans dans
des luttes moi c'est quelque chose qui
m'intéressait qui m'attirait en fait
j'avais du mal j'ai du mal à le
déterminer
tout ça c'est des décisions qu'on prend
jeunes et dieu sait que les décisions
qu'on nous impose à l'école ou comme
suggère de prendre à l'école sont
difficiles à prendre
et puis on diverge plusieurs fois
parfois en début de carrière avant de
trouver vraiment sa voix on va justement
vous évoquez ce fameux stage pour
intégrer les commandos marine un stage
digne vraiment d'aider film de commando
la réalité dépasse totalement la fiction
je sais pas c'est l'impression qu'on a
si la réalité dépasse la fiction
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que c'est dur
c'est un passage qui est difficile et
qui n'est pas impossible
parfois on idéalise certaines choses ou
les dramatise alors qu'en fait parfois
avec une préparation de sérieuses on
peut arriver déjà à de grandes choses
mais déjà la préparation sérieuse
c'est quelque chose qui est parfois déjà
difficile en soi donc
donc je comprends que ça puisse recruter
et paraître incroyable mais en fait pas
c'est incroyable que ça les commandos
marines qui repousse les limites il ya
un moment marquant lorsque vous décrivez
ce stage commando c'est lorsque vous
courez serein sur un grandin pendant ce
temps un candidat justement comme vous
faites une chute grave mais vous vous
êtes obligé de continuer ça sur le
terrain ça ne peut pas arriver aux usa
et surtout on est on est très encadré
pendant le stage commando on a les
instructeurs qui veillent sur nous en
permanence
donc moi mon premier réflexe a été de
consulter instructeur et c'est lui qui
me dit quoi faire c'est c'est un peu nos
mamans pendant le stage commando ils en
font voir des vertes et des pas mûres
mais ils sont très bienveillant et il
nous aide à nous amener au plus loin de
ce qu'on est capable donc c'est lui qui
m'a permis de
le destin qui m'a dit quoi faire dans
cette décision là évidemment que la d67
ce genre de situation pardon dans une
situation de combat avaient complètement
différente
durant trois mois vous avez fait face à
ce qu'il ya de pire et de meilleur dans
la nature humaine
vous êtes vous parvenu à ne pas céder au
pire si si moi j'ai cédé au pire j'ai
essayé au pirée et comme tout le monde
je pense
en fait il ya toujours un moment où on
fait voilà on va faire des choix et des
choix qui parfois sont difficiles et
clairement ch
moi je pense pas qu'ils quelqu'un qui
puisse sortir du stage en disant moi
j'ai été parfait tout du long du stage
la perfection n'est pas de ce monde
malheureusement sur le terrain pour
réussir une émission vous dit qu'il vaut
mieux privilégier les affinités
l'expérience la maîtrise la technique ne
suffisent pas il faut vraiment être en
osmose avec ces équipes c'est ce que
vous dites
lorsqu'une analyse personnelle moi je
j'apprécie beaucoup travaillé avec des
hommes avec lesquels je m'entends et je
pense que ça doit primer sur tout mais
ça c'est un travail de longue haleine
c'est un travail de confiance et un
travail de maturité mais une fois qu'on
s'entend bien avec quelqu'un cette
personne de toujours progresser
techniquement mais vous avez la garantie
de bien vous entendre avec elle et ça
c'est fondamental
pourquoi la raison pour laquelle j'ai
dit ça c'est parfois ils ont constaté
des guerres d'ego parfois ou des guerres
de deux techniciens des techniciens plus
ou moins bon mais l'essentiel au fond
c'est que vous ayez confiance les uns
dans les autres
telle est la technique finalement ça
devient presque secondaire par rapport à
la confiance vous accordez c'est le cas
d'ailleurs lors de votre première
opération vous êtes alors chef de guerre
depuis un an et demi et votre mission
cette capture et un boulanger dans une
ville africaine soupçonner un sou
boulanger est soupçonné de fournir des
informations 10 à 10 710 l'ont quand
même sur ce terreau de la pauvreté sur
lequel justement les groupes djihadistes
is leurs toiles d'araignées
je ne suis pas sûr que 110 non vous
pensez que la pauvreté est lié avec
l'extension du jihad
en fait c'est vrai que c'est un terreau
qui peut favoriser l'extension du
terrorisme et du jihadisme effectivement
les de nombreux leaders activistes
profite justement de cette pauvreté des
populations pour pouvoir instrumentalise
et ses populations
vous l'avez probablement remarqué sur le
terrain disons que le djihadisme a
effectivement enfin le l'islam radical
tout est tendance et dans ces pays-là
très facilement
je pense qu'il ne faut pas imaginer
qu'il suffit simplement d'avoir un pays
pauvre pour que l'islam s'étendent
il ya certains pays très pauvre où
l'islam n'arrive pas à se développer
parce que vous pouvez avoir une
idéologie dominante ou un sens religieux
dominant qui ne laissera pas la place à
l'islam radical
donc je pense que le facteur de pauvreté
est un facteur je suis d'accord avec
vous mais ce n'est pas le seul
et c'est là où je pense qu'il ya eu
négligence c'est que je pense que
aujourd'hui enfin en tout cas beaucoup
de la lise qui le montrent que le
l'islam radical est aussi un prédateur
de sociétés riches voire très riche
on a des jeunes qui qui ont des
situations très confortable parfois
qu'ils peuvent verser dans l'islam
radical et la pauvreté n'a rien à faire
là dans ces situations là et d'ailleurs
vous le dites dans votre ouvrage qu'il
faut combattre l'idéologie aussi lisse
haillan on va marquer une courte pause
et on va se retrouver dans un instant
pour poursuivre cet entretien avec vous
on se retrouve dans un instant sur rt
france rester avec nous
[Musique]
retour dans la grande interview nous
sommes avec luis ayant ex commando
marine et auteur de cet ouvrage chefs de
guerre aux éditions mareuil luis ayant
on parlait donc de cette première
opération que vous avez menées
lorsque vous étiez commandos marine dans
une autre opération aussi que vous
décrivez vous capturer le chef d'un
groupe ennemi vous précisez bien et me
c'est une notion importante ce mot et
demi parce qu'on fait la guerre a pas
d'autres personnes que nous aidons lui
c'est quand même intéressant de se poser
la question est ce que est ce qu'il faut
justifier le fait qu'on fasse la guerre
des miss qui ont fait la guerre c2c nos
ennemis c'est la définition enfin ça
fait partie de la définition de la
guerre si ces panneaux et demi alors on
leur fait pas la guerre et par exemple
ce boulanger c'était un ennemi un bain à
partir du moment où vous avez des
accointances vous faciliter le travail
de l'ennemi vous devenez son complice
lorsque vous c'est comme dans la cité
civile lorsque vous avez un criminel qui
qui a commis un braquage
celui qui conduit la voiture du braquage
n'était pas peut-être dans le braquage
mais c'est un complice il a facilité le
travail du criminel donc ça devient par
état de fait 1 un criminel lui aussi
alors le pire le pire échec vous dites
c'est de perdre des otages ne pas
pouvoir les sauver
vous vous étiez sur les lieux d'une
attaque terroriste dans un restaurant
mais vous ne pouviez pas agir ça c'est
vraiment pire que tout voilà c'est pire
que tout c'est un souvenir que très
difficile c'était alors vous dit pas
exactement où
où cette attaque se déroule mais je
pense que c'était en 2010 est au burkina
faso il attaque dans un restaurant de la
capitale le bilan une dizaine de morts
dont un français
je voudrais pas un détail si je les hais
l'amour pas dans le coup cas alors en
tout cas en tout cas les forces loyales
les forces loyales
sur place vous l'expliqué bien refuser
votre aide pour cause d'ingérence
cela révèle quoi sur la perception de
votre présence de l'armée française au
sahel je pense qu'il n'y a aucun lien
je pense que c'est plus une histoire
d'hommes c'est une histoire de de
souveraineté et de hiérarchie en fait on
a les mêmes problèmes
aujourd'hui sur le territoire national
lorsqu'on voit qu'il ya différents
groupes qui peuvent se côtoyer sur une
opération et que on va établir une
hiérarchie qui peut ou le petit peu
judicieuse ou pas donc on a le même le
même problème je pense notamment au
bataclan et à différents prise d'otages
qui ont mené à des situations un peu
délicate entre les différents groupes
d'intervention mais cette présence dans
cette région du sahel vous savez cette
présence militaire étrangère elle est
quand même de plus en plus contestée est
ce que vous l'avez ressenti non non les
populations sont très bienveillante
elles sont au pire des caleçons neutre
mais n'ont pas de d'animosité envers
nous contrairement à ce qu'on peut
croire les gens sont plutôt bienveillant
ils nous font généralement un bon
accueil et c'est quelque chose qui est
plutôt positif et il faut que ça reste
comme ça alors vous reprochez aux forces
d'intervention locale de vous avoir
empêché d'agir lors de cette attaque
dans ce restaurant d'une ville africaine
est ce que quelque part quand il n'y a
pas une forme d'arrogance vis-à-vis des
armées africaines
lorsqu'il y a une vie qui est en jeu je
pense qu'on peut mettre tous ces
sentiments de côté en fait seule la
compétence doit primer et l'essentiel
est d'arriver au plus vite au secours de
ceux qui en ont besoin
c'est tout ce qui prime il faut mettre
de côté tous ces sentiments il faut
mettre de côté tous et toutes ses
commandes et un son ego l'orgueil aussi
parce que c'est vrai qu'à une forme et
sentiments humains finalement faut
savoir les mettre de côté pour faire
primer la la survie vous auriez pu
voulait sauver vous en est certains vous
auriez pu sauver ses otages si vous
étiez intervenus à temps on est certain
de rien mais ce qui est certain c'est
que le camp magie pas mais plus de
chances que ça marche pas parce que vous
avez évolué dans cette région du sahel
au burkina faso au mali
vous avez certainement côtoyé aussi
d'une façon ou d'une autre les armées
loyalistes les armées locales
il ya une forme d'humiliation qui est
ressenti par ces armes et vis-à-vis de
la population parce qu'elle n'arrive pas
à les sécuriser
vous le comprenez ça je pense pas moi je
pense pas parce que je pourrais avoir
effectivement des forces locales
généralement c'est des gens qui sont
déterminés
c'est des gens qu'on est des vrais
guerriers pour le coup vraiment
valeureux j'ai eu des situations
incroyables où il arrivait à mettre
l'ennemi en échec et c'était c'était
vraiment du comportement exemplaire
maintenant c'est plus d'un point de vue
structurel je pense que c'est délicat
puis s'ils ont des structures qui sont
fragiles donc on a une base de guerriers
qui est très bonne et très efficiente
mais dès qu'on monte dans la hiérarchie
chez les plus fragiles peut-être plus ou
moins expérimentés avec des cadres qui
sont plus fragiles dans l'eure dans
leurs fonctions
donc c'est essentiellement là où ça
pêche en tout cas c'est mon analyse
c'est vrai que dans cette région mais
beaucoup en avant l'action à deux des
militaires français
des forces européennes notamment il ya
le g5 sahel par exemple au moment de la
guerre au mali la france a beaucoup
vanté son intervention sans jamais dire
véritablement que l'appui des soldats
tchadiens dans l'adrar des iforas ça a
été fondamental pour remporter cette
guerre au mali écoutez moi j'ai pas de
notion exactes sur leurs actions là bas
mais tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que c'était les tchadiens sont des
guerriers incroyable ils sont d'une
ténacité d'efficacité qui est hors norme
et surtout davantage de ces hommes là
c'est qu'ils sont chez eux ils
connaissent le terrain ils connaissent
tous les chemins de leur pays comme on
dit et ça c'est un avantage qui est
incroyable dans des guerres de guérilla
on parlait tout à l'heure de cette
notion d'ennemi vis-à-vis de l'ennemi
djihadistes vous dit éprouver une forme
de respect comme les soldats vous dites
il donne un sens finalement à leur
existence
ce qu'on a du mal à comprendre c'est
l'aspect de l'an bragg l'embrigadement
tous ne sont pas en vega des je pense
que le terme embrigadement implique
qu'ils n'ont pas fait une action qui
soit raisonner par laure conscience
c'est pas une action qui est raisonnable
une action intelligente où tout leur
conscience s'accordent dans cette action
là donc je pense qu'il y en a qui sont
embrigadés c'est à dire qui ils ont été
séduits ils ont été manipulés et
d'autres qui agissent de manière
parfaitement consciente et lucide dans
ces activités là donc c'est un distinguo
qui est très délicat à faire mais qui
est réel pour revenir sur les
combattants djihadistes je respecterai
toujours mon adversaire même si je
méprise totalement son idéologie comme
c'est le cas pour ces jihadistes
d'ailleurs vous côtoyez des soldats aux
six américains c'est ce qui vous dit
c'est ce qui vous différencie aussi le
côté un peu chevaleresque de l'armée
française on a une vision du monde qui
est différente avec les américains
effectivement c'est c'est difficile à
définir
moi je n'entends toujours très bien avec
les opérateurs américains les petits
chefs américains que je peux rencontrer
à mon niveau
on a toujours une entente qui est très
facile mais dans la vision du monde et
ça on peut le voir depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale avec certes un
bombardement américain en europe et avec
une certaine forme d'hégémonie
américaine sur le continent européen
il y a une vision du monde que nous ne
partageons pas exactement on a un
ensemble qu'on n'a pas la même culture
on sent qu'on vient pas alors on est
originaire de la même civilisation
mais selon moi il ya eu des divergences
qui sont nées notamment de leurs afin de
leur côté anglo-saxon qui est un peu
dérivé dans le temps le palais pilot gay
mais c'est un sujet qui est assez
intéressant pour le coup merci beaucoup
louis saillants ex commando marine je
recommande bien évidemment votre ouvrage
chef de guerre passionnant aux éditions
mareuil merci beaucoup pour cette grande
interview passionnante une grande
interview vous pouvez retrouver en
replay sur nos réseaux sociaux et notre
site internet arte france point tva très
bientôt
[Musique]